gibt es außerirdisches leben wie
entwickeln sich planeten und woher kommt
die erde
warum es die sonnenatmosphäre so
unglaublich heißt es gibt noch so
unendlich viele ungeklärte fragen zum
universum und antworten auf diese fragen
könnte es vielleicht noch dieses jahr
geben denn derzeit sind wir
beispielsweise mit spektakulären
missionen nicht nur auf den weg zur
sonne oder zum mars auch der merkur ist
eines der ziele der menschheit genauso
wie sich auch bei der erforschung von
asteroiden dieses jahr noch so einiges
tun wird wir stellen die spektakulärste
mission vor herzlich willkommen bei
klicks um science-fiction schön dass ihr
dabei seid hier gibt es täglich neue
science videos abonniert den kanal gerne
[Musik]
ich kann mich nicht entscheiden welches
ist die spektakulärste weltraum mission
ihr könnt am ende darüber abstimmen also
schaut genau hin und macht das auch am
kommenden dienstag dann gibt es unseren
weltraum livestream mit allen fragen und
antworten zur raumfahrt und 1930 geht es
für mitglieder und patches los und um 20
uhr für alle
und jetzt also vier super spannende
weltraummissionen nasa-raumsonde insight
auf dem weg zum mars anfang mai dieses
jahres ist die nasa-raumsonde insight an
bord einer atlas rakete zum mars
gestartet eigentlich war die rund 650
millionen teure mission schon für 2016
geplant doch das verzögerte sich dann
wegen eines undichten forschungs
instrumentes die landung auf dem mars
soll im november stattfinden inside
steht dabei für in terrier exploration
using seismik investigation ski und die
sea and transport auf deutsch innen
exploration mit seismischen
untersuchungen geodäsie und
wärmetransport auch das deutsche zentrum
für luft- und raumfahrt dlr ist
beteiligt und die forschungsteams offen
nicht nur mehr über den mars sondern
auch zur entstehung der erde zu erfahren
dazu tilman spohn vom dlr
der mars ist als ziel idealer ist gut zu
erreichen und ein ideales
vergleichsobjekte zur erde und damit
wird ein großer traum der
planetenforscher und forscherin war denn
schon lange wollte man ein
geophysikalisches observatorium auf
einem erdähnlichen planeten aufbauen
konkret soll die mission herausfinden
wie der mars aufgebaut ist hat er einen
flüssigen oder festen kern wie groß
ist der planeten kern überhaupt wie ist
der mars mit kernmantel und christa
aufgebaut dafür wird in side den
wärmefluss des mars untersuchen und
erdbeben messen ein seismometer wird
erschütterung untersuchen bis zu 100
beben auf dem mars erwarten die
forschungsteams in den nächsten zwei
jahren alle nicht stärker als 6,0 auf
der richterskala die raumsonde soll sich
dafür fünf meter tief in den boden des
mars grab und dort die temperatur und
wärmeleitfähigkeit messen mit den
ergebnissen erhoffen sich die
forschungsteams endlich mehr über die
entstehung der gestand planeten in
unserem sonnensystem zu erfahren denn da
wissen wir nur sehr wenig der länder
ähnelt vom design her übrigens der
raumsonde phoenix die 2008 auf dem mars
gelandet war
anders als curiosity wird inside
allerdings stationär an einem ort
bleiben japanische raumsonde hayabusa 2
auf dem asteroiden drew schon 2014 war
die raumsonde hayabusa 2 gestartet ende
juni 2018 hat sie dann ihr ziel fast
erreicht den asteroiden hugo die
japanische raumfahrtagentur jaxa meldete
dass die sondern sich nur 20 kilometer
von rio befindet und von dort aus
messungen vornehmen werde
zudem soll von dort auch nach einem
geeigneten landeplatz gesucht werden
dazu der missionsleiter marco yoshikawa
wir waren alle sehr erleichtert wir sind
weit gekommen aber jetzt beginnt der
eigentliche teil der mission
hayabusa 2 wird in den nächsten
anderthalb jahren den asteroiden
vermessen der übrigens 300 millionen
kilometer von der erde entfernt liegt
2020 soll die sonne dann zur erde
zurückkehren und proben mitbringen die
bei einem dichten überflug eingesaugt
werden auch an bord ein deutscher mini
roboter namens mass scott der aus einer
höhe von 100 metern auf den asteroiden
absinken soll und zwar im freien fall
wobei fall ist hier etwas übertrieben
das wird wohl auch eine der größten
herausforderungen zum einen die trennung
von der mutter sondern und zum zweiten
die landung selbst rio hat so gut wie
keine gravitation etwa so viel wie ein
kleiner berg auf der erde es ist mehr
also wie ein andockmanöver an die
internationale raumstation iss der
länder soll dann auf dem hast du ihnen
bleiben überwacht wird das zehn
kilogramm schwieriger
weg von köln aus mit dieser mission
wollen die forschungsteams mehr zu den
ursprüngen des sonnensystems erfahren
asteroiden view sind überreste aus der
frühzeit unseres sonnensystems
nasa-sonde parker auf den weg zur sonne
nach mehreren verzögerungen war es mitte
august 2008 10 soweit die nasa hat ihre
700 kilogramm schwere parkas solar sonde
in den äußeren teil der atmosphäre der
sonne geschickt wir haben darüber
berichtet durch das schwerefeld der
venus soll sie auf eine elliptische bahn
gezogen werden so würde die sonde auf
700.000 kilometer pro stunde
beschleunigt und wäre somit das
schnellste menschengemachte objekt
überhaupt sie soll das magnetische feld
der sonne untersuchen und vor allem zwei
große rätsel lüften warum ist die äußere
sonnen atmosphäre deutlich heißer als
die oberfläche und wie werden hier die
sonnenwinde auf einen wert im überschall
bereich beschleunigt und verstoßen so
scheinbar gegen die naturgesetze dazu
nicola fox eine wissenschaftlerin des
nasa sonden projektes der entstehungsort
des sonnenwindes die atmosphäre der
sonne ihre corona muss extrem
energiegeladen seinen 300 mal so heiß
wie die oberfläche der sonne
das widerspricht den naturgesetzen es
sollte keine wärmequelle geben die
heißer wird wenn man sich von ihr weg
bewegt dort gibt es irgendeine
zusätzliche energie irgendeine schwarze
magie der solar- wind- löst sich nicht
einfach von der sonne
er nimmt irgendwie auch ihr magnetfeld
mit sich egal in welche richtung es
zeigt wie stark es ist es erstarrt im
sonnenwind einige rätsel also rund um
die sonne
die es zu lösen gilt gilt dabei wird
nicht erst seit gestern in diesem
zusammenhang geforscht den november 2018
soll sich die sonne dann das erste mal
der sonne annähern und in den nächsten
sieben jahren weitere 25 mal an der
sonne vorbei fliegen im dezember 2024
wird sie dann ihren sonnennächsten punkt
wohl das erste mal erreichen jedes mal
werden die fluktuierenden magnetfelder
und die geladenen partikel gemessen und
so hoffentlich alle rätsel zu den sonnen
winden aufgeklärt hat so nicola fox am
spannendsten wird unsere erste dichte
annäherung sein
die wird zwar noch nicht am missionsziel
von zehn solarien sein sondern
erst war etwa 35 radien aber das ist
immer noch viel mehr als alles andere
zuvor wir werden und kartierte das
gebiet erreichen einen bereich mit der
warnung hier sind drachen genau das ist
spannend dort zu sein wo noch niemand
anderes war die forschungsteams
versprechen sich neben einem größeren
verständnis für die sonne auch sehr
konkrete praktische anwendung sie wollen
durch die hoffentlich neu gewonnenen
erkenntnisse die sterne generell aber
auch die wirkung der sonne auf das klima
den klimawandel und das wetter besser
einschätzen können baby colombo mission
zum planeten merkur märkte ist mit einem
durchmesser von knapp 4200 kilometer nur
ein bisschen größer als der erdmond und
damit der kleinste planet des
sonnensystems er ist der sonnennächste
planet und durch die europäische
japanische mission bepicolombo will man
nicht nur erkenntnisse zur entstehung
des gesamten sonnensystems bekommen
sondern zu den erdähnlichen
terrestrischen planeten überhaupt doch
das ganze gestaltet sich gar nicht so
einfach denn in der merkur umlaufbahn
ist die sonneneinstrahlung achtung
zehnmal höher als auf der erde
und das müssen instrumente und
satelliten auch erst einmal überstehen
eine weitere herausforderung stellt die
anreise da denn der merkur ist im
gegenteil zum mars oder zu venus nur
durch ein langwieriges ab bremsmanöver
erreichbar konkret wird die sonde die
gravitationskraft von merkur venus und
erde nutzen um durch neun manöver den
absturz ins sonnensystem innere
abzubremsen
die baby colombo besteht aus zwei
satelliten zum einen aus dem japanischen
merkel magnetosphäre kredite mmo und zum
zweiten aus dem europäischen mercury
planetary orbiter mpo beide werden auf
unterschiedlichen umlaufbahnen unterwegs
sein um den merkur zu erforschen die
japanische sonde wird sich vor allem
sein magnetfeld vornehmen und auch das
wechselwirkung mit dem sonnenwind
untersuchen die europäische sonde soll
dagegen auf einer niedrigeren umlaufbahn
unterwegs sein und die innere
zusammensetzung des planeten erforschen
konkret sollen unter anderem die
folgenden fragen beantwortet werden ist
der kern des merkurs fest oder flüssig
ist der planet tektonisch aktiv
und wie sind die krater an den polen
beschaffen die permanent im dunkeln
liegen staaten soll die mission im
oktober 2018 und zwar mit einer
ariane-5-rakete vom weltraumbahnhof
kourou die reise zum merkur wird
insgesamt sieben jahre dauern
ob sie erste ergebnisse gibt es also ab
2025 unter dem ihr oben
da könnt ihr jetzt abstimmen welches ist
die spannendste mission und warum ist
die jeweilige mission die spannendste
für euch das schreibt bitte in den
kommentaren
und wenn ihr keines der ergebnisse der
mission verpassen wollte auch zu allen
anderen denen kein video mehr verpassen
wollt dann habe ich am ende dieses
videos einen kleinen tipp für euch wenn
ihr beim mitglieder livestream am
kommenden dienstag dabei sein wollt dann
werdet mitglied hier unter dem video
draufklicken oder auf den link in der
video beschreibung und ihr bekommt noch
exklusiver extra wieses eben live
streams und noch ein paar weitere
privilegien für einen kleinen beitrag
und zudem machen wir mit euren beiträgen
klicks um werbefrei und jetzt mein tipp
wenn er immer garantiert über aktuelle
videos informieren werden wollt dann
hättet mich bei whatsapp nur da bekommt
ihr das aktuelle video deutlich vor
allen anderen von mir persönlich auf
euer handy einfach draufklicken und
darunter geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken 1000 raketen zum mars bis
dann bleibt dran